[Applaudissements]
regarde regarde et je suis croque à
domicile concorde comme il ya 14 mois
nous ici on a cas de mathieu daris que
là vous êtes les noeuds sans déconner on
dirait les deux vieux tu me plais à
pédales et ira renshaw cullin merci non
là bas merci à vous d'ailleurs vous avez
déjà fantasmer sur quelqu'un bah oui sur
qui ballotte asie parce que dîtes moi
et à part ça vous allez dire le truc et
après je vais rend l'antenne parce que
je dois partir ok très bien dont je vous
le dis il s'agit d'un homme attend
puissant il ya de l'argent qui a
beaucoup de pouvoir qui a beaucoup de
joueurs sur et comme tu si 90% qui a
beaucoup de charme et qui est elle a
commencé sur d8
c'est quelqu'un qui aime bien les fans
les jolies femmes elle lui rendent bien
attention juste un truc hein j'ai juste
dit que j'allais fantasmer quoi rien ne
s'est passé beaucoup est d'accord que je
parle du bon à s'agit donc de vincent
bolloré
non le grand patron oui absolument mais
la censure vachon cimade a soumis à tous
le pouvoir la dune de charme
il a fédéré vers aux tic j'ai un moment
donné à aller dans les premiers temps de
les rencontrer je suis choquée certes il
est très charismatique les ben oui non
mais pas du comprendre
bien sûr il vous regarde pas non non
bien sûr il n'ya pas y arriver sans
qu'il le sache vous n'avez jamais dit
[Applaudissements]